hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 14 video escape from
zoom Mountain just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet I'm gonna
need to explain who edward clariss is
from the comics and where velocity-9
originally came from and there's a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so really big stuff first there
were some teasers at the end of the
episode but the reason I have jaws up
here on my monitor is because they
released a jaws promo for the King shark
episode next week it's gonna be so much
fun
we'll talk about that later we have to
talk about zoom stuff right now so I'll
start with a really big stuff first we
found out the person knocking behind the
glass we didn't find out who they are we
know there are a white person because we
can see their skin right here but they
were banging Jay Garrick on the glass
and that could mean a lot of things it
could mean I'm really Jay Garrick or it
could mean Jay Garrick is zoom but
because of the end of the episode we
know that our Jay Garrick the one that
we've been saying this whole time is not
zoom zoom is still someone else so until
we get more information that's gonna
make make us shift our theories a little
bit it seems like what they're doing is
they're combining things from the
reverse-flash from the golden age edward
clariss with things from modern day like
hunter zolomon and cobalt blue what does
that mean well it means they take
aspects of the Golden Age reverse-flash
and make him look like more modern
reverse flashes give him a backstory
that's a little bit closer to one of the
more modern reverse flashes but I really
love the idea that zoom is gonna have
something to do with a deep cut from the
Golden Age Jay Garrick era of comics Jay
Garrick earth-2 huge part of season 2 it
makes sense that you would do a lot of
Golden Age villain type things
velocity-9 what the hell is that
velocity 9 is the formula that edward
clariss
tries to recreate to give him the powers
of Jay Garrick the speed of Jay Garrick
in the comics now there been a couple
different ways that they've explained
Jay Garrick getting his powers it was
not through the lightning like Barry did
like you'd expect the original versions
a little silly he was conducting a lab
experiment and accidentally inhaled
heavy water vapors activating the
meta-gene giving him SuperSpeed so when
we're klaris takes the velocity-9
formula becomes an evil speedster starts
being called the rival eventually during
their final battle Jay Garrick is taking
him down edward clariss goes so fast he
reaches Lightspeed in Van
she's into the speedforce for about 50
years and they haven't done this on the
show yet but the speedforce in the
comics is an actual place that you can
get trapped in this nether region like
an alternate dimension almost that
exists out of space and time
so the reverse-flash comes back he has
blue looking Lightning a darker version
of jay garrick's costume there's a twist
though when he does come back he's pure
energy he inhabits the body of max
mercury one of Jay Garrick's friends
another speedster in pretends to be him
while he tries to take down Jay Garrick
again so it sounds like zoom is a
version of edward clariss the TV shows
version of that just combining it with
some modern-day things now I still don't
know his backstory we don't know how
much he's changed from the comics and
what his face is gonna look like when he
takes it off if he's gonna look like Jay
Garrick that might be the case but I
just I like the idea that they're gonna
play with what the meaning of the Speed
Force is on the TV show that's one thing
that they didn't really push into in
season 1 it was just about Barry
learning to use it but the Speed Force
itself is a fairly complex phenomenon
there's still 9 episodes left in the
season so they're just gonna continue to
tease out zoom backstory but now that
I've explained the big stuff we do top
10 WTF so number 10 Cisco super duper
recap I love the way they do recaps
sometimes at the beginning of episodes
as if Cisco's whole speech at the
beginning where he's SuperSpeed explains
to harrison wells what happened last
week is to remind casual viewers what
happened like Oh in case you missed part
of last week's episode all this WTF just
happened number 9 WTF Barry one meets
Jessie quick and we're gonna get a whole
bunch more Jessie quick I'm so excited
as we learn she's kind of down in the
dumps I don't know how long you know in
terms of time frame how long she'd been
captain but it looks like zoom has
started to break her spirit number a WTF
zoom versus the Time Vault
I love that there's an earth 2 version
of the Time Vault that Harrison wells
created as if to say he's every bit as
smart as the reverse-flash who's from
the future a genius in the far future it
seems like this version of the room is
more of a holodeck just you know really
complex holograms cannot actually see
into the future Cisco just calls it the
Time Vault number 7 WTF zoom is a giant
when he runs up to Jessie quick
and it's like I'm only keeping you alive
to kill you in front of your father and
I'm only keeping him alive so that I can
take your speed that was just the most
Hardcore thing ever they really want you
to hate that character and they're doing
an amazing job of making him visually
terrifying along with just being scary
in general
number six WTF Scott Evans iris West
from Earth ones new editor at the paper
is also a giant but for slightly
different reasons he just wants to push
the narrative that the flash isn't the
hero that we think he is now we just met
him we don't know if he hates the flash
for a specific reason but I think we'll
find out they said that he and iris are
gonna have some sort of chemistry
together eventually
that's TV code for sexual chemistry as
in like everything up to actually
hooking up like I don't I don't think
iris is gonna be hooking up with him
anytime soon but once she jumps over the
hump of thinking he's an like oh
my god this guy hates the flash he's a
total bag of dicks she'll realize that
he has a specific reason for wanting
that he'll be much more complex they'll
build the character out he'll be a lot
more interesting but I'm in favor of
anything that gives iris an interesting
story to tell right now all the really
cool stuff she does is involved with
Wally West's storyline and with Barry's
storyline so all the characters really
need to have like stuff going on in
their own lives independent of team
flash number five WTF earth to Barry
we'll just call him Barry - Barry - meet
Cyrus - and explains the multiverse and
he is like the uber Felicity we learned
number four WTF that patty spivot of
Earth - is a CSI like in this er she
didn't put it off compiled all the
information they need on all the
metahumans of Earth - and Barry - is the
one that created the algorithm that
allows them to search for people so he
really is like the Felicity of Earth -
but he totally nuts up number three WTF
as they find killer frost and Cisco
convinces her that she's not a total
and she wants to help them out
because of what zoom did to Ronnie they
get Barry the confidence boost he needs
to phase out of his prison and escape
with killer Frost's help and I know it
seems like she might be dead but if you
don't see a body if you don't see her
head on an ice spike
she's still alive consider her still
alive number two WTF the man in the iron
mask pounds Jay Garrick on the glass so
I kind of already explained how I think
that there's some edward clariss Golden
Age stuff going on
maybe cobalt blue it's gonna be a
mixture of reverse-flash things but I do
think they're going deep cut with a lot
of Jay Garrick Golden Age comic stuff
and I know there was the trailer that I
posted where it looks like zoom is
ripping his
ask off that had footage from future
episodes so we're probably gonna see
that scene sometime in the next two or
three episodes and number one WTF of
course team flash returns with Jesse
quake and Harrison wells
but zoom reaches through and seemingly I
know it seemed like he killed Jay
Garrick cuz he sucked him through the
remains of the portal but I don't think
that he's dead yet if they wanted to
kill our version of Jay Garrick he would
have fallen dead right there instead of
being sucked back through the portal
so everybody let me know in the comments
what are all your zoom theories now that
we know that the guy was pounding Jay
Garrick on the clasp let me know in the
comments do you think whoever he ends up
being he will look like Jay Garrick
it'll be like a cobalt blue Golden Age
reverse flash explainer either way I'm
super happy with what they're doing with
the villain it's way more complex way
more interesting than we ever thought
which is just one more reminder that you
should trust the flash writers they
totally know what they're doing they're
totally gonna do something awesome
whatever the explanation ends up being
and I know I don't talk about it very
often but the special effects are
amazing like just that last sequence
where Jay Garrick has two SuperSpeed run
around the portal to keep it open and
Joe West has to like tap that little
piece in just like oh just nudge it just
a little bit to fix it boom we're good
that's just really cool looking and it's
good from a story perspective well at
least we know how long velocity-9 lasts
now speed which that was actually one of
my bigger surprises from the episode
that Caitlin was like okay you know
we're working on velocity eight we'll
see how it works and then a couple
minutes later she was like hey you know
what I completely fixed it we're on
velocity nine now like boom done I
didn't expect them to perfect velocity
nine till at least like three or four
more episodes it does make me wonder why
the producers were saying the velocity
nine is gonna be a big part of wally
west and Jesse quick storyline just
remember the cool thing here Jesse quick
the smartest person on the show as
confirmed by Barry and her father so
team flash is now like team super
science they have all the smartest
people on the show all in one room so
what's gonna happen is is I have a
couple other videos to post I just
posted a game of Thrones Q&A YouTube is
kind of slow with uploading so hopefully
this video didn't take forever but I'll
be posting updates on Twitter and
Facebook for the next couple of videos
new arrow new flash king shark next week
on the flash that is going to be badass
well you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for the Star
Wars Episode eight
they just posted that was actually
pretty big surprise and you can click
here for all my other flash and arrow
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight